and i told that this is what i'm going
to do and my father basically said all
right on that family dinner said why
won't you hook with idan who is my
brother
and that had a very small boutique
consulting firm for ait that's how
commit was born
was born and
nowadays you know we have 530 employees
generating more than 250 million shekels
a year
and profitable from the first year
and doing it completely bootstrap no
external investment no nothing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel and in media
partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today is all about serial
entrepreneurship meet alec feingold
chairman of
kumiti is an entrepreneur and advisor to
startups and capital fund groups and the
president of commit he has over 20 years
of business development experience in
the global technology sector combined
with a vast knowledge of software design
development and system architecture
eric successfully completed a number of
exits and co-founded several ventures
including pantera formerly cysus a fully
automated self-learning penetration test
solution that mimics the hacker's
mindset and betting core which provided
gaming platforms and real-time
transaction management
alec feingold welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm fine thank you
thank you for hosting me michael
i'm so on i i can't believe i have the
chance to sit with people like you and
and
get your complete attention for 20
minutes and i'm going to make use of it
as much as i can alex serial
entrepreneur serial founder and
executive your he co-founded a betting
corp
sizes which is now pantera which which
add another episode which is an amazing
amazing company
and also the co-founder and chairman and
president of comet and talking about
you know global development of
cutting-edge technologies and providing
those services before we get to commit
walk me through
what what the journey of a serial
entrepreneur
maybe start by
talking what it means to be a serial
entrepreneur in your mind because
because you know it's pretty amazing
so i think you know
being serial entrepreneur is
is basically always focusing on
building new things
on trying to find you know new
new things that will change new needs
right pains in the in the world that are
looking for a for solutions
and to act upon them many many of you of
us basically you know we see paint all
of the time but only few
are really
acting on it or actually making the move
and sometimes again being still
entrepreneur and i don't know
everything i i'm actually i
i don't know most of the things
right but it's about finding the right
people and the right knowledge that i'm
missing
but still identifying identifying the
pain in specific markets
right and and looking for the best way
to solve it
so that's about serial independent
so what i'm hearing you say is when
you're approaching a problem you're
looking at it not just as the person who
might potentially run through with the
pro with the problem until the end but
you're looking at it from a higher
perspective a bird's eye view saying i'm
actually a strategist and i need to put
the right people together and maybe
sometimes i am not the right person to
lead the company right
that's right you know
you mentioned pantera pantera i
established in 2015 together with alec
liberton who is the co-founder and he's
the cto and basically this is the
company that is now is the world leader
in automated penetration testing and
and the pain was obvious that cyber
security is becoming bigger and bigger
problem and nobody really validates
their security posture right right now
i'm not a cyber person but i i but i
realized that there is a problem so i
found again i was lucky because i knew
ali from before right so i basically
approached her and said
hey man you have the knowledge all right
let's build something and that's the
hope sciences nowadays called pantera
been built and the first two years we're
not just about building the solution but
also building the right team
right to lead the company to where it is
today
including ceo and vp marketing and vp
product and all the functions
again i'm not part of those functions
but as a chairman and founder
i had the privilege to build that team
incredible okay so we're already we're
already in the middle of the journey but
take me back a little bit more the
creation of a serial entrepreneur what
does it mean to go through this journey
both personal and professionally for you
and then we'll reach commit
so basically i started
back in 2000 so i was 23 years old
student in my second year of computer
science
and and i had an opportunity basically
talking to a business person
right
in my first venture he was basically he
was the first one that identified a
specific pain which is a pain for
multi-platform gaming
so
back then again remember 2000
the the notion of playing
television against
pc against mobile
was kind of you know
a artificial science
etc so
he came with that pain i was a second
year
computer science student and i had the
nerve
to become a co-founder and cto
of that journey
and in three years building
a great product that we managed to sell
to
leading broadcasters around the world
including biscuit in the uk and nbc
universal in the u.s and still that was
my first exit at the age of 26 and sell
to open tv part of liberty media group
in the us
and so that's how i became the general
manager of open tv israel
and then you know in 2008 there was an
economic crisis
and opentv worldwide they were looking
to for ways to cut costs uh but i ran a
worldwide pnl there so they offered to
close the israeli office and to move me
and few people to san francisco
and again this is being an entrepreneur
is all about out of the box thinking so
i came and said listen you know you need
to close the office in israel let's
close the office i will open a new
company all right that's how commit was
born and we'll get to that in a second
which will be a services company another
product company and you will be your
first customer so you will be able to
show that you save costs and you manage
to close the office and i will get my
back you know my entrepreneurial freedom
in order to build my own company again
and
we sat
on a friday night dinner at my
grandmother
uh
you know rest in peace
and i told that this is what i'm going
to do and my father basically said all
right on that family dinner said why
won't you hook with idan who is my
brother
and that had a very small boutique
consulting firm for a it
a a networking solution and i come from
the software world
why won't you hook together and you will
have them you will be we have a stronger
services company and that's what we did
on that dinner
that's how commit was born uh was born
and
nowadays you know we are 530 employees
generating more than 250 million shekels
a year
and profitable from the first year
and doing it completely bootstrap no
external investment know nothing
so
how we got and in 2015 we spoke about
pantera
i don't know many people that are
that are starting a company by having
their first customer sign before the
company is even born i think i think
that's pretty remarkable especially for
the time when it was you know this is
not 2021 where you have a proliferation
of design partners and then you know
people are trying out these different
sas products here you're having a
company that is providing services and
it which requires reputation requires
brand requires time relationships
and you have it and you got it what is
commit you know in in the strategy way
of thinking
so commit it firstly is a services
company it's a technology powerhouse
right
it's it's a company we
again as an entrepreneur that like to
build things
it's all about you know
building dreams so if you have a vision
right if you have a dream we will build
it for you there are a lot of
entrepreneurs that are around the world
that are not technological people and
they're not technology people right they
they have a dream they have a great idea
they
they notified a pain point right
and they need someone to hold their hand
and be able to
make it happen
right to build whatever product or
platform that they that they need
and this is what committee is all about
on top of that
it's about making it very cost effective
again in 2008 a
i had a my second degree on an executive
mba in tel aviv university and in
operation schools
right we learned
that
in high-tech in the technology
technology companies there is more than
40 percent waste
right of basically
you know
how else that are basically
being lost i either because people are
just sitting around and not or doing
nothing or that they are actually doing
things that are not really what
the company or the product or the
project needs right and that's that and
i learned that
and i anno and i made it in my own
research and
realized that yeah in is it's a minimum
40 percent waste some companies it gets
to 70 and 80 percent
because of the nature of
of building a high-tech platform today
when you build the arctic platform and
hide the product
you need
many different disciplines you need 400
engineers back-end engineers your
engineers product people cyber people
cloud people devops big data data
platforms et cetera et cetera
now the typical journey is that you
recruit everybody in-house
but the truth of the matter is that you
don't really need all of them
all the time and they're waiting for
each other and the truth the real truth
of the matter is that
well especially when you're a startup
that you don't have a lot of money when
you're at the early stages
you want to build your mvp
go to the product and cut your burn
right cut the bleeding
get the real feedback from the market
and then move to the second phase so
that's how we came with our notion of
flexibility which basically solved the
problem it's think about it
about it like a cloud of people
that we can manage a project and product
and we can bring in and out from our
powerhouse of 530 people
of multi-disciplines the right people at
the right time
in order to get your product out there
on time on budget without the waste
incredible what have you learned over
the last 13 years of providing these
services the world has changed
organizations have changed organizations
have both matured but they've also
become much younger because we've had a
proliferation of younger entrepreneurs
that are starting out companies what
what are what have you been learning
looking at it from a bird's-eye view
about how the world of of r d is
shifting
so first of all the world of r d became
discentric than ever right and
especially in the last year and a half
because of kovid
okay so everything goes to the cloud so
if back in the old days you needed all
the engineers in the same room or at
least in the same building working
really close to each other in order to
be a productive
nowadays it's it's obvious that you know
the fact that
you and me we might be living in the
same town or the same city
but in the last year and a half most of
the time
we communicated in room
and we worked on the cloud so for
developers nowadays the r d became very
global
right so so you and you can see it on
offshore you see you know global
engineers from ukraine and india
working together with israeli engineers
working together with you yeah us-based
engineers so it became
really really global and you can do
everything from remote
and therefore it's all about
how do you really manage
the team
and how do you get the right talent
worldwide not just looking you know at
your own right
and
with commit
what what
what common threads are you seeing with
the people that are
that are leveraging commits power of r d
so what what what types of problems are
are more common to be solved using a
global service company like commit
rather than internal r d
you know
today especially
you know the first the biggest problem
that everybody uh
everybody trying to solve is the lack of
gunpowder basically so
all right so people are trying to get
good talent and it's very very hard
so the fact that
i have
few hundred people that we control and
we can move them around in a very
flexible way that's the first biggest
problem which is time to market and the
ability to scale
and the second biggest problem
is really about
the know-how
right and they know
it's on the niche area so it might be
that
you just establish a company and you
have a very good measure you said you
know you have you come from a machine
learning and artificial into
intelligence that background so
this is an excellent background right
and you might be able to be in in
in the company that you will establish
that would be the core
right but now you need them a mobile
interface
right now as a as a being a great
machine learning developer
i'm not so sure you know how great
a machine learning developer is about
building a mobile interface so it's
about getting the right more the best
mobile interface developer in order to
build the best mobile platform
that will basically
reveal
the logic and the magic
i love the machine i think what i'm
still pondering about is what you said
about this idea of skill this question
of
we're starting out with a project we're
going to need to grow this project once
we figure out our poc is working we want
to scale our time to market is is really
crucial
and
hiring is almost impossible even if you
do have the money right and we're seeing
it but having the flexibility through a
company like commit who's providing the
service that can just you know shift
people around because you have hundreds
of people i think that's really really
interesting and where so where are we
heading from here you know if you're
looking three four years down the line
where do you think we're heading as
either you know r d
organizations or generally company
speaking
i think that rnb organizations will
become
more and more global
the trend you know the trend started a
few years ago but in the last year and a
half became you know
extremely massive
and i think that we will see it
getting you know growing bigger or
bigger you know from a global
perspective
i think that we'll see a trend about
really you know and there is
opportunities of building tools right
there are some good tools out there but
there will be there will be need to
better tools because now you know you
have different cultures different time
zones different
geographies that needs to cooperate with
each other more than ever
so there is an opportunity there
uh
and i and i believe if you ask me in a
few years i think that big part of what
we will do what the developers are doing
will be done by the machine all right we
will see that we will see a new trend
of machine learning coding
right that will do a lot of the stuff
and that's something for the developers
to remember
all right that's why you need to keep
amazing
this was so so great i have a few last
questions but they're but they're back
to you and i want to take you back all
the way to your childhood and i want you
to tell me what fascinated you as a kid
and before you thought about being a
serial entrepreneur
you know as a kid
i got my
my first computer on atari when i was
like
i think it was in in the fifth grade
and it fascinated me that suddenly
i can play
a game on the screen
right so so it started with hey
how fun it's great fun but then it came
to
how do i do that
all right so i started to learn how to
build the games but once you get to
once i learned how to build games i
realized that
you can build more than games you can
build many different things and almost
any idea
so that fascinated me and that's how it
inspires you today you've you've working
on a lot of different things
and i and i and i'm expecting a few more
a few more amazing things to come from
from your mind in the in the next years
what what inspires you on a daily basis
i think that what inspires me you know
you know it's all about building things
right and again
i'm looking at giants you know elon musk
and the and you know the real big giants
that are that are really breaking you
know that looking to mouth and looking
to the space and looking to solve you
know huge problems
and some of the entrepreneurs that i'm
working with you know the so
it's about the fact that you know every
day
there are new things and the world is
changing and there are basically no
limits and
exploring those knowledge so what i'm
hearing is about the the serial
entrepreneurism it's not a profession
it's a characteristic that you just have
it's just it's a part of who you are
it's it's a bug
it's a passion i think what are three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
entrepreneur
a courier
and founder
what's the difference
oh starter oh you know
no that yeah yeah so so entrepreneurial
curiosity
and
building i love it
this is so enjoyable stay safe and stay
healthy thank you very very much